j'ouvre le second débat de ce sens
public vous le savez en choisir
régulièrement de ne pas coller à
l'actualité du jour aujourd'hui c'est un
portrait d'Elon musk que je vous propose
le patron de Tesla spacy Twitter devenu
x pèse de plus en plus sur la scène
internationale économique mais aussi
géopolitique peut-il influencer le cours
de la guerre en Ukraine avec ses
satellites roule-t-il pour Donald Trump
sa conception de la liberté d'expression
était le dangereuse pour nos démocraties
beaucoup de questions dont on parlera
beaucoup de thèmes dont on parlera dans
quelques minutes mais d'abord l'histoire
d'un gamin de Pretoria devenu l'homme le
plus riche de la planète avec Cécile
sixs
[Musique]
une entreprise privée qui envoie des
fusées dans l'espace c'est le pari fou
d'Elon musk quand il a créé sa société
SpaceX en 2002 et ce rêve de conquête
spatiale ne s'arrête pas là
l'objectif de Space X c'est un grand
objectif nous voulons essayer de rendre
la vie multip lanétaire d'étendre la vie
au-delà de la terre et je pense que
c'est important pour un certain nombre
de raisons
allez sur Mars pour la
rue peine de satellites envoyer orbite
par ses fusées Elon Musk est un patron
sans limite qui a force d'ambition est
devenue l'un des hommes les plus riches
de la planète avec une fortune estimée à
235 milliards d'euros sud-africain
d'origine il mise sur la vague internet
fin des années 90 avec un premier
business de logiciel et une banque en
ligne devenue Paypal revendu à prix d'or
ces millions il les réinvestit en
pariant sur le futur avec Space X mais
aussi Tesla devenu championne de la
voiture électrique et plus récemment
Twitter renommée x qu'il voudrait rendre
payant
j'avais l'impression que Twitter
évoluait de plus en plus dans une
direction négative et mon espoir mon
aspiration était de changer cela et d'en
faire une force pour la civilisation une
personnalité capable de tout comme lors
de ce show télévisé où il fume du
cannabis en direct chacun de ces gestes
et paroles à des conséquences notamment
sur les places boursières comme
lorsqu'il annonce la fin du paiement des
Tesla par Bitcoin derrière le
visionnaire et l'entrepreneur talentueux
se cache une façon révélée par la
biographie de Walter isaction paru le
mois dernier elle dépend un homme
colérique et brutal autant dans sa vie
personnelle que professionnelle aux
méthodes de travail tyrannique et
capable de licenciement violent
on va commencer sur ce sur ce thème la
personnalité d'Elon musk avec mes
invités Olivia lascar bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue heureuse de vous accueillir
vous êtes rédacteur en chef du pôle
digital de Sciences et Avenir la
recherche auteur d'un livre sur Elon
Musk en quête sur l'homme qui défile la
science chez alisio et puis votre
dernier livre paru toujours chez lisio
abysse l'ultime frontière Amel Guiton
bonsoir bienvenue à vous vous êtes
journaliste à Libération spécialiste des
enjeux numérique Florent Parmentier
bonsoir et bienvenue secrétaire général
du cevipov Sciences Po chercher au
centre de géopolitique de HEC évidemment
Laetitia que pas est resté à mes côtés
effectivement ce portrait d'Elon musk là
Olivier rescar donc le livre dont
parlait Cécile il paraît en France cette
semaine il est paru je crois ce mercredi
visionnaire ça d'accord mais visionnaire
brutal très sombre rongé par le doute
par la colère pour vous c'est un
portrait vous qui avez vraiment enquêté
sur lui est-ce que c'est un portrait un
peu forcé juste qu'est-ce que vous en
dites non c'est en porte c'est un
portrait qui est en rés avec tout ce que
on a pu découvrir des lones musk avec le
rachat Twitter parce que Elon Musk il
est dans le paysage depuis fort
longtemps mais pour ceux qui
s'intéressent à l'actualité du numérique
à l'actualité industrielle au spatial
aux voitures etc mais avec le rachat
Twitter il est devenu autre chose Elon
Musk il est devenu il s'est placé au
centre de l'Agora mondial et
effectivement on a pu voir avec le
rachat Twitter devenu x comment il était
capable de liquider les équipes on l'a
vu avec les spécialistes de la
modération qui ont quasiment disparu ça
fait des milliers de personnes en mois
dans Twitter donc c'est quelqu'un qui
est extrêmement cassant c'est un des
paradoxes du personnage qui à longueur
de temps va expliquer que sa mission
c'est de sauver l'humanité il a pas
calculé que l'humanité était composée
d'humain quoi ça commence avec ceux avec
qui on travaille au quotidien évidemment
Amel Guitton c'est aussi on l'a dit dans
le sujet il faut le rappeler un génie du
business c’est-à-dire il a souvent eu ou
souvent un coup d'avance sur ses
concurrents oui
je sais effectivement depuis que depuis
qu'il a racheté Twitter et depuis qu'il
s'exprime beaucoup et puis
iquement on en a effectivement une
vision on va dire très très critique et
qui à mon sens et parfaitement justifié
mais c'est vrai qu'il faut pas appeler
il faut pas oublier que avant ça il est
l'un des fondateurs de l'ancêtre de
Paypal avant ça il y a effectivement
dans Tesla avant ça il y a surtout SPAC
ici que son y reviendra mais SpaceX qui
est objectivement une vraie réussite
est-ce qui d'ailleurs le met aussi au
centre du jeu notamment géopolitique
avec lui aujourd'hui et donc
effectivement il a provoqué je pense
assez longtemps une forme de fascination
et d'admiration notamment dans les
sphères tech dans les sphères un peu
geek qui aujourd'hui a tendance
effectivement à se désagréger au vu d'un
certain nombre de prises de position et
de la manière pour le coup je trouve
assez
erratique et difficilement
compréhensible au demeurant dont il gère
twittera évidemment longuement dans ce
débat sur sur ce chapitre Twitter
Florent Parmentier on est en train de
dire que c'est quelqu'un qui casse les
codes des secteur d'activité dans lequel
il a débarqué l'automobile l'espace etc
d'ailleurs on va parler de géopolitique
c'est aussi le cas quand il propose un
accord de paix sur l'Ukraine on se dit
de d'où ça sort quoi de la part d'un
Elon Musk effectivement pour mémoire le
3 octobre 2022 il y avait fait une
proposition qui consistait à dire et
bien que les modalités du de la guerre
en Ukraine elle est dans de telles
directions qu'il fallait prendre un
certain nombre de prise de position il
fallait faire un certain nombre de prise
de position pour dire en substance qu'il
fallait laisser de côté la Crimée
regarder différemment les territoires
perdus donc il était totalement à
contre-courant à la fois ce qui allait
se passer à l'automne puisque la
contre-offensive Ukraine de l'époque a
admirablement bien marché il y avait
permis de libérer d'énormes quantités
territoire
et l'état de ce point de vue là un petit
peu dans une position intéressante c'est
à dire l'homme d'affaires l'ingénieur
qui pense que à tout problème on peut
trouver une solution c'est cette espèce
de l'ingénierie une autre grille de
lecture en se disant je rejoins ce qui a
été dit juste auparavant c'est-à-dire
oublier parfois que pour
informer la planète faut s'appuyer sur
des hommes mais en l'occurrence
effectivement il a aussi su ou a été
contraint de froisser un certain nombre
de personnes par rapport à ce plan de
paix alors que quelques mois plus tôt on
a vanté ces mails dès lors qu'il était à
même avec Starling et bien de permettre
à quelque chose d'important qui est la
connectivité de l'ensemble de des forces
armées
ukrainiennes on sait que dans une guerre
moderne la dimension cyber est
importante ne serait-ce qu'en termes de
coordination différentes armées donc il
a été à la fois un héros et un scélérat
successivement pour le peuple ukrainien
on y vient c'est cette constellation de
de satellites l'une des forces
effectivement des lones et ce qui
explique son poids géopolitique
aujourd'hui et c'est d'autant plus dans
l'actualité que ce livre dont on parle
cette biographie
a révélé donc ça sort cette semaine en
français c'était il y a un mois aux
États-Unis qu'il aurait bloqué une
offensive majeure de l'armée ukrainienne
en coupant l'accès à son réseau de
satellites peut-être un mot
d'explication un peu de pédagogie car
c'est quoi c'est quoi cette
constellation de satellite alors
Starlink c'est vraiment un enfant de
Space X d'abord avec SpaceX il s'est
donné le moyen d'envoyer notamment des
satellites dans l'espace et en envoyant
des satellites dans l'espace il s'est
donné les moyens de constituer cette
méga constellation c'est-à-dire un
maillage de l'espace
constitué par des milliers de satellites
qui dialoguent les uns avec les autres
en quelque sorte et plus ce maillage
était trois plus il permet d'arroser
l'entièreté du globe avec un Internet
tombé du ciel quelque sorte aujourd'hui
98% du web vient de la terre et même de
sous l'eau des câbles sous-marins il y a
que 2% qui vient de l'espace mais ces 2%
peuvent être déterminants dans des
situations
conflictuelles
c'est ce qui se passe en Ukraine les
réseaux terrestres étaient plus étaient
plus efficients d'une certaine façon et
donc en donnant accès parce que au début
de l'histoire ce sont les Ukrainiens qui
lui demandent d'ouvrir le service
Starlink à leur armée ça veut dire
concrètement envoyer des petites
terminaux extrêmement mobiles qu'on peut
poser sur le toit d'une camionnette ou
qu'on pose sur le terrain des opérations
ça permet d'accrocher les ondes qui
tombent du ciel et ça permet de renvoyer
et de commander par exemple des drones
qui sont devenus c'est la guerre des
drones l'Ukraine les drones sont pas
contrôlables
elle se rend publique ça semble quand
même incroyable mais c'est la question
qui se pose parce que aujourd'hui on
voit un individu un patron quelqu'un qui
n'a été élu par personne qui est capable
d'influer de modifier le sort d'une
guerre des facto c'est ce qui se passe
il le fait avec
la partie la participation peut-être de
l'acteur public les États-Unis en
l'occurrence ont acheté aussi des
terminaux Starling puisque il faut tout
ça n'est pas magique il faut quand même
des petites antennes qui vont être
disposées sur le sol donc les États-Unis
ont joué le jeu ont payé des terminaux
mais quand même la prestation technique
et le savoir-faire technique vient de
SpaceX et alors donc on remonte le fil
début du conflit début de la guerre en
Ukraine invasion russe effectivement il
y a le fait que Elon Musk accepte
d'ouvrir le réseau Starlink au fort
sucrénienne et puis donc il y a ce fait
j'y reviens réveillé dans le dans le
livre donc il est accusé d'avoir bloqué
une offensive contre qui visait la
flotte donc les bateaux russes alors
voilà ce que Elon Musk a tweeté après
avoir appris qu'il y avait cette
accusation il dit je refusais d'être
complice d'un acte de guerre majeur les
autorités gouvernementales ont demandé
d'urgence d'activer sterling jusqu'à
Sébastopol là il parle du gouvernement
ukrainien évidemment l'intention
évidente étant de couler la majeure
partie de la flotte russe au mouillage
si j'avais accepté Space X aurait été
explicitement complice d'un acte de
guerre majeur et d'une escalade du
conflit Hamed guython Elon Musk peut-il
prendre cette décision sans en avoir
référé aux autorités américaines
notamment au Pentagone alors en fait
c'est là que c'est intéressant parce que
dans le livre de Walter isaction ils
axonne écrit que musk a pris la décision
de couper l'accès à sterlink pour éviter
que cette attaque se produise ce que lui
dit est d'ailleurs Isaacson est revenu
c'est qu'en fait il a juste refusé
d'activer Starlink qui alors
qu'effectivement il y avait cette
offensive donc de drones maritime le
sujet sais pas et le sujet est tout sauf
anodin c’est-à-dire que dans la
biographie aussi Walter isaction dit en
fait musk se pose la question du rôle de
son entreprise dans ce conflit et c'est
une question qui n'est pas illégitime en
fait tout ce que ça révèle c'est
qu'effectivement aujourd'hui la place de
Starling concrètement dans l'espace dans
l'espace physique et si prépondérante
que effectivement
il ne peut plus rester en dehors d'un
conflit alors il semblerait quand même
que ça ait un peu impacté effectivement
du côté du Pentagone qui depuis a passé
des accords dont le contenu n'est pas
public mais à passer des accords avec
musk parce que qu'un patron d'une énorme
entreprise dise je n'ai pas forcément
moi à être parti prenantes d'un conflit
entre état c'est pas un point de vue
illégitime en fait la question c'est un
moment donné qui a les clés qui décident
puisque tout ça effectivement c'est
c'est pas une décision qui peut prendre
de lui-même effectivement sans alors
est-ce qu'il y a eu une discussion avec
le Pentagone à ce moment-là ça semble
pas très clair et effectivement à lire
ces déclarations on aurait plutôt
l'impression que non il y en a
certainement eu après c'est assez
évidentes d'une certaine façon puisque
là on est en train de se poser la
question est-ce qu'il a choisi un camp
plutôt qu'un autre
si on regarde les choses on observe que
il n'a pas influencé le cours de la
guerre à tel point que les Ukrainiens
seraient plus en mesure d'aller taper la
Crimée on observe aujourd'hui la
question est peut-être qu'il a ralenti
le processus pour autant est-ce que si
ce processus avait lieu plutôt fait du
contrefactuel
le guerre de la fin le sort de la
contre-offensive n'a été
fondamentalement différent je pense que
la réponse est plutôt non donc de ce
point de vue là je pense qu'il ne faut
pas exagérer ce soin en revanche ce qui
est important d'observer c'est la
fatigue de l'opinion publique fatigue
l'opinion publique par rapport et des
alliés occidentaux de alliers
occidentaux on verra dimanche les
élections en Slovaquie dans deux
semaines nous avons les élections en
Pologne qui devraient confirmer un peu
ce point et c'est peut-être de ce point
de vue là que une parole comme Elon Musk
a une capacité d'influence supérieure
effectivement à un certain nombre de
points et d'une manière générale on peut
dire que sa voix porte plus qu'un
certain nombre de chefs d'État quand
lui-même c'est l'accusation qui est
contre lui laisse revenir regarder
trolaurus sur sur Twitter alors
l'accusation est de dire qu'il contribue
en quelque sorte à ce que et bien on
finisse par se dire que la cause
ukrainienne fait peut-être plus de plus
de tort que qu'autre chose l'acteur
géopolitique on va on va le démontrer en
images tiens il y a 10 jours il
rencontrait le président turc on va voir
ces images le patron de Tesla qui est
venu d'ailleurs avec son fils et on voit
Récept Taipe air de renky offre un
ballon de football voilà au petit garçon
aux autres rencontres alors là on est au
mois de mai dernier mi-mai avec Emmanuel
Macron voilà l'image le prénom
République qui reçoit vous en souvenez
ce jour-là c'était plus de 200 grands
patrons de multinationales étrangères
pour tchuss friends 6e édition il
accorde un entretien bilatéral à Elon
Musk quand même comme un chef d'État
étranger autre exemple avec naran
dramodi le Premier ministre indien là on
est à New York on est le 21 juin et
juste après le rendez-vous écoutez Elon
Musk qui parle de quoi il parle de
business
j'apprécie beaucoup maudit il a visité
notre usine de Frémont il y a plusieurs
années nous nous connaissons depuis un
certain temps l'Inde compte vraiment
pour maudit il nous pousse à faire des
investissements importants dans son pays
ce que nous avons l'intention de faire
nous essayons simplement de trouver le
bon moment voilà j'aurais pu en rajouter
beaucoup un des visites il y a 3 jours
de visite en Chine où les traités comme
un comme un ministre il voit tout le
monde alors il voit pas que c'est d'une
pin mais il voit tout le monde sinon
donc c'est quand même assez intéressant
est-ce que Olivier lascar les politiques
qui rencontrent musk et je rebondis sur
ce sonore là qu'on vient qu'on vient de
vendre il voit d'abord l'investisseur
qui peut installer une usine créer des
emplois enfin voilà il voit cette manne
économique avant tout je pense
s'agissant de la France c'était pas tant
quand Macron l'a reçu c'était dans
l'espoir de décrocher de la part de musk
l'annonce de l'installation d'une usine
Tesla en France ce qui n'est pas arrivé
et là manifestement c'était la même
teneur de discussion avec avec le
Premier ministre indien c'est ce que en
tout cas c'est ce que nous dit Elon Musk
donc l'impression qu'on a quand on le
voit à rencontrer tous ces chefs d'État
c'est qu'il les tient un petit peu par
les par la barbichette quoi à chaque
fois et effectivement sur des
considérations d'ordre économiques
s'agissant de la Russie il faut aussi
bien voir que parce qu'on dit est-ce que
musk avait pris fêté cause pour lui
graines et ce qu'il était contre la
Russie
musk ne peut pas aller trop loin dans
son opposition à la Russie d'une part
parce que la Chine est prorus et musk a
un besoin de la Chine absolue parce que
c'est le marché numéro un Tesla et
d'autre part le seul endroit au monde
aujourd'hui où il existe encore une
collaboration entre les Américains et
les Russes c'est la Station spatiale
internationale bien sûr c'est l'espace
et SpaceX est devenu le seul taxi
américain pour l'espace et il envoie
encore des équipages qui sont constitués
en partie par des Américains et des
Russes il y en a un qui est revenu sur
terre il y a il y a trois jours
donc il discute avec les Russes ils
discutent forcément avec les Russes il
faut rajouter à ça que d'un point de vue
de sa formation intellectuelle musk il
est très sensibilisé à la culture de la
technologie russe cette obsession qu'il
a à partir dans l'espace à faire
installer l'espèce humaine dans l'espace
ça vient du père de l'aérospatiale russe
qui s'appelait silkowski j'ai peur de
d'écorcher son nom mais c'est l'auteur
de cette phrase célèbre qui disait que
la terre et le berceau de l'humanité et
personne ne reste toute sa vie dans son
berceau il faut essaimer partout et la
première fois qu'il a voulu se lancer
dans Space X son premier réflexe a été
d'aller dans l'ancienne Union soviétique
pour essayer d'acheter des missiles des
militarisés qui auraient pu devenir ces
premières fusées ça a pas marché il les
a construit lui-même et donc il y a une
grande porosité entre entre musk et la
Russie depuis le début très intéressant
on y reviendra un peu plus tard on
parlera des des liens entre musk et la
Russie des liens entre musk et et Donald
Trump mais là je voudrais vraiment qu'on
se concentre sur
Twitter chapitre Twitter écouter tiens
d'abord Elon Musk ce qui lui dit des
questions de liberté d'expression
c'était à Paris justement une séance de
questions-réponses à devant
3600 fans de de tech écoutons Elon Musk
nous voulons permettre aux gens de
s'exprimer sur Twitter et vraiment la
liberté d'expression est importante et
n'est pertinente que si les gens sont
autorisés à dire des choses que vous
n'aimez pas sinon ce n'est pas de la
liberté d'expression je considère que si
quelqu'un dit quelque chose de
potentiellement offensant c'est en fait
acceptable nous n'allons pas promouvoir
ces truites offensant mais je pense que
les gens devraient pouvoir dire des
choses l'internative ce serait la
censure et franchement je pense que si
vous vous engagez dans la voie de la
censure ce n'est qu'une question de
temps avant que la censure ne se
retourne contre vous
rebonsoir Tam traduis Elon Musk qui a
acquis Twitter en étant d'octobre 2022
le moins qu'on puisse dire qu'ici c'est
pas contenté de changer les plantes et
de d'installer des ficus le réseau
social a bien changé et oui comme
effectivement l'indique son nouveau nom
adopté au mois de juillet dernier en
passant de l'Oiseau Bleu à X la lettre
fétiche d'Elon musk omniprésente dans
toutes ces entreprises le réseau est
bien il a subi du coup des changements
brutaux marque du nouveau propriétaire
qui a acheté le réseau pas moins de 44
milliards de dollars et là d'abord mis
au régime sec avec le licenciement de
80% des salariés passer d'un peu moins
de 8000 à 1500 personnes et puis la
diminution drastique de la modération
avec la suppression de milliers de
contrats de prestataires l'art comme
estime qu'aujourd'hui il y a seulement
149 personnes qui sont chargées de cette
tâche en Europe une goutte d'eau donc
tout cela parce qu'elle a une musc a une
conception très large on l'a entendu de
la liberté d'expression son premier
tweet au moment c'était d'ailleurs ce
Bud is thride l'oiseau est libéré et
l'une des premières décisions a été de
rétablir les contes qui avaient été
bannis notamment celui de Donald Trump
après un simple sondage qui avait été
fait sur le propre compte d'Elon musk
dès à cela l'absolutisme libertarien
d'Elon musk mais aussi des raisons
économiques et d'ailleurs Elon Musk a
commencé à rendre le réseau payant
expliquez-nous c'est un autre axe fort
de sa stratégie la première étape
c'était au mois de décembre 2022
lorsqu'il faut désormais payer 8 dollars
par mois pour avoir droit à on la voit
la fameuse pastille bleue synonyme de
compte certifié alors qu'auparavant et
bien la pastille identifiait les contes
de personnalités publiques désormais la
pastille payante permet de voir moins de
pubs permet de publier des tweets des
vidéos plus longues ça permet aussi
d'avoir pour les comptes les plus actifs
une rémunération par exemple le compte
alerte info en France avait reçu il
l'avait publié sur son compte Twitter
6850 euros au mois d'août et chaque
semaine quasiment ben on découvre des
nouvelles fonctionnalités qui sont
devenues payantes à leur qu'auparavant
elles étaient gratuites objectifs passés
d'un modèle assis sur la publicité à une
économie de l'abonnement peut-il aller
encore plus loin ce n'est qu'une piste
pour l'instant mais le milliardaire
réfléchit et a effectivement à rendre
l'intégralité du réseau payant écouté
je dis que la raison principale pour
laquelle nous évoluons vers un petit
paiement mensuel pour l'utilisation du
système X
et que c'est le seul moyen auquel je
puisse penser pour combattre de vastes
armées de robots
les robots dont il parle ce sont les
contes générés par des programmes
informatiques qui sont là pour amplifier
certains messages souvent ce sont des
messages politiques ou des messages de
haine et donc ce que dit Elon Musk c'est
que un robot aujourd'hui ne coûte
quasiment rien en revanche il va ce
qu'il faut payer pour un abonnement et
bien ça reviendra beaucoup plus cher ça
serait donc un moyen de lutter contre
ces robots et contre la haine en ligne
notez qu'il a dit cela au moment où le
Premier ministre israélien à Benjamin
Netanyahou était en visite dans la
silicone Valais et l'interroger alors
sur l'antisémitisme sur le réseau une
question qui est aussi intervenue alors
quelon musk est accusé d'encourager
l'antisémitisme sur Twitter X et que
certains américain au même qualifié le
réseau de fosse septiques merci beaucoup
tam-trani pour toutes ces explications
je me tourne vers vous je vais vous
poser à peu près la même question je
commence avec vous à Mel Guitton ce
nouveau Twitter ce qui s'appelle x donc
maintenant est-ce que c'est encore plus
un danger pour nos démocraties à cause
de cette modération de plus en plus
faible alors je sais pas exactement
comment répondre à la question au sens
où
de la manière dont il évolue oui et en
même temps je peux pas m'empêcher de
penser qu'il y a un moment où ça ne va
plus fonctionner et peut-être
s'effondrer de soi-même ce qui serait
une manière de régler le problème
parce qu'en fait ce qui est ce qui est
assez frappant c'est que il y a chez
musk qui est un libertarien purfruit
cette idée qui est assez y compris assez
inspiré des théories de la cybernétique
qui devrait y avoir une espèce d'ordre
naturel de l'information que les
interactions entre entre les
utilisateurs finalement créer quelque
chose
des choses et notamment vous le disiez à
l'instant sur le fait d'avoir
véritablement mis à nu les équipes de
modération c'est qu'il y a une espèce de
alors je sais pas si ça relève de l'auto
aveuglement sur le fait qu'il y a
évidemment besoin que que de modération
sur ce type de réseau oui mais Olivier
Lasserre ça c'est alors c'est peut-être
pire aujourd'hui sur Twitter mais cette
question de la modération elle se pose
sur à peu près tous les réseaux sociaux
tous les médias sociaux aujourd'hui on
peut même dire que le modèle économique
de ces réseaux sociaux repose sur la
modération la plus faible possible oui
non
je n'irai pas jusque là et je n'irai pas
non plus jusque
ce que vous dites c'est-à-dire les
mettre tous dans le même sac
effectivement Twitter sous l'air musk
c'est un c'est un extrême de l'abolition
des limites sous des arguments qui sont
qui sont fallacieux musk qui se campe en
champion de la liberté d'expression
alors qu'il est le seul à parler chez
Tesla chez SpaceX chez neuralink et que
on l'a vu le premier à l'intérieur de
ces sociétés qui dit une parole
divergence divergente il est liquidé
les bottes les bottes ça coûte peut-être
pas cher à l'unité ça coûtera sans doute
plus cher quand on y aura une armée de
bottes mais effectivement comme comme ça
a été dit si c'est un acteur si c'est la
Russie qui paye les bottes il leur
abonnement problème à faire le chèque le
calcul de musk tel qu'il le présente
totalement cynique qu'il est en train
d'inventer en disant ben je sais très
bien que ceux qui utilisent aujourd'hui
x puisque ça s'appelle x maintenant pour
pour manipuler l'information
continuerons de le faire même si ça leur
coûte beaucoup plus cher oui moi j'ai
l'impression que le le
l'erreur je sais pas si une erreur c'est
de se concentrer sur la question de
Twitter en ne voyant que Twitter il
s'agit pas de regarder Twitter parmi les
autres réseaux sociaux il s'agit de
regarder Twitter par rapport aux autres
activités de musk d'accord l'obsession
de musk c'est pas de venir le nouveau
Zuckerberg l'obsession de musk c'est de
faire que c'est pas non plus de devenir
le nouveau Trump c'est à dire de
s'installer à la Maison Blanche ou dès
que le nouveau Schwarzenegger est le
gouverneur on a titré nouveau maître du
monde avec un gros point d'interrogation
devient un maître du monde s'il devenait
maître du monde c'est par le truchement
de la réussite de ces entreprises son
obsession c'est le spatial la réussite
du fait qu'on puisse demain aller sur
Mars alors ça je j'ai prévu le tout
dernier chapitre d'y revenir donc je
vous donnerai la parole mais ça va ça
forme un dire que Twitter c'est le
levier c'est-à-dire dans le temps les
grands de l'industrie s'achetaient de la
presse des magazines etc ces tisane Kane
et compagnie aujourd'hui on est passé
dans le numérique et avec Twitter il a
un levier formidable pour faire la
promotion de ses activités industrielles
quand il y a un lancement de SpaceX il
suffit d'aller voir sur Twitter toutes
les chanding topics sont consacrés sont
accrochés aux mots clés qui sont liés à
cette activité donc sans doute que il
gagnera jamais beaucoup d'argent avec
Twitter la question est de savoir
jusqu'à quel point il peut en perdre
mais si ça lui permet de demeurer le
numéro 1 dans le privé spatial ou dans
la voiture électrique le jeu en veut la
chandelle de son point de vue quoi ouvre
aussi encore plus quelques portes de
chef d'État ou de gouvernement quand on
voyait le tout ce qui le qui le
reçoivent Laetitia ce pouvoir d'Elon
musk il réside selon vous justement dans
cette maîtrise d'une d'une forme de
propagande mondiale grâce à X grâce à
toi carrément un outil de propagande et
je crois effectivement que l'aspect
économique de X n'est pas du tout
l'enjeu là pour Elon Musk l'enjeu c'est
de maîtriser un outil surpuissant Thomas
de propagande mondiale on n'est pas
uniquement dans les démocraties
occidentales et uniquement aux
États-Unis c'est à dire qu'il peut agir
sur les équilibres géopolitiques ça aide
il a bien compris et c'est x donc
Twitter est vraiment cet outil qui peut
changer les équilibres pour cela je vous
propose tiens un conseil lecture le
dernier ouvrage d'un chercheur
enseignera Sciences Po David colon qui
écrit là aux éditions talentielles ça
vient de paraître la guerre de
l'information et lui parle notamment
d'Elon musk comme un des acteurs
principaux de cette guerre d'information
et dans ce livre il nous explique selon
lui pour qui roule Elon Musk vous avez
raison il n'a pas d'impression politique
ce n'est pas un homme politique c'est un
entrepreneur mais il sert des intérêts
politiques selon David Colomb c'est sa
thèse il roule pour Donald Trump et pour
la Russie donc vous voyez bien que Elon
Musk dans ce cas là et dangereux alors
on va en débattre évidemment sur ce
plateau parce que ce réseau social x ex
Twitter est incontournable en politique
c'est pour ça depuis Donald Trump c'est
devenu essentiel fondamental pour tout
ce qui est communication politique
intérieure c'est à dire chef d'État à
son le peuple dictateur à son peuple
mais aussi pour finalement la diplomatie
mondiale c'est devenu un vecteur
fondamental et puis on voit bien
qu'aucun chef d'État n'y échappe ni
aucun journaliste ça doit être payant
peut-être dans quelques temps on verra
si les journalistes sont bons pourquoi
sortir un petit moment depuis que depuis
que a pris la tête
je suis parti bref pourquoi c'est
intéressant de voir qu'il y a à la fois
les chefs d'État et les journalistes
parce qu'on comprend bien que c'est un
outil de fabrique de l'opinion publique
et c'est ça aussi le risque et le danger
majeur de X parce que quand on fabrique
les opinions publiques ici elles
échappent à tout ce qui est formation
classique politique que l'on connaît et
donc sont par définition incontrôlables
de la presse ou des médias traditionnels
c'est un peu le rêve de tout politique
d'ailleurs exactement alors pour cela je
vous renvoie un autre ouvrage c'est un
peu ma voilà un chronique libre c'est
pour moi vraiment laisser culte qu'il
faut absolument lire pour comprendre
tous les enjeux aujourd'hui de la cyber
guerre d'information la cyber Egger que
l'on est en train de vivre les
ingénieurs du chaos de Giuliano dame
poli raconte tout il raconte comment le
mouvement 5 étoiles premier régime
populiste en Italie c'est installé au
pouvoir et comment Thomas en utilisant
les nouvelles technologies d'abord le
blog de BP grêlo c'était un blog à la
base et puis les réseaux sociaux
cette stratégie de
monter en et de prise de pouvoir
été qui a choisi BPG pour incarner cette
nouvelle voilà ce nouveau pouvoir et qui
s'est ensuite appuyé sur tout ce qui
était nouvelle technologie ça a marché
en Italie vous le disiez dans les années
2010 donc on comprend pourquoi X et lon
musk s'il décide de servir un régime
politique sont à mon avis majeurs là
aujourd'hui de la Garde information on
est toujours au cœur de cette de ce
chapitre sur
l'impact finalement de la stratégie
d'Elon musk sur le fonctionnement de nos
démocraties via l'utilisation notamment
de X Florent Parmentier est-ce que pour
vous musk roule pour Trump c'est une
question très basique qui demande
peut-être une réponse complexe mais elle
est est-ce qu'elle est légitime déjà
cette question
oui elle est tout à fait légitime je
pense que si on regarde les choses et si
on les remet en perspective premier
élément Twitter contribue à une forme de
polarisation de la vie politique c'est
aujourd'hui que la vie politique
américaine est beaucoup plus polarisée
c'est-à-dire qu'en gros on arrive à un
moment où un électeur démocrate ne prend
pas la même marque de bière qu'un acteur
républicain les deux sont vraiment
séparés c'est pas les mêmes réseaux etc
donc il y a des phénomènes avec des amis
qui vivent aux États-Unis dans même au
sein des familles avant on pouvait quand
même dialoguer entre républicains
démocrates c'est devenu compliqué c'est
devenu compliqué précisément pour ça
comment ça marche et bien typiquement
Donald Trump pouvait faire une de
déclaration sur Fox News mais ce qui
marchait encore plus c'est la manière
dont le compte Twitter reprenait
certains extraits bien précis de manière
j'allais dire à propager un certain
nombre d'idées et à provoquer du clash
c'est-à-dire de la polarisation
d'obliger à faire des clivages de
manière à avoir ça c'est le premier
élément de polarisation un deuxième
élément sur lequel x Twitter est
intéressant c'est la contribution en
quelque sorte en l'érosion de la
confiance
institutionnel la confiance dans les
institutions dans les démocratie sont
sur le recul depuis pour comparer le cas
de la France on a le baromètre de la
confiance politique
chaque année ce rapport évidemment là
pas faire de liens causal entre
seulement Twitter et c'est un facteur
d'environnement aggravant qui amène à
remettre en cause la parole publique et
à mettre en fait un pied d'égalité entre
un expert qui aura travaillé 20 ans sur
un sujet une personne qui a une opinion
en gros contribuer à la confusion entre
l'analyse et l'opinion
Wason notamment pour tous ceux toutes
celles et ceux qui travaillent sur le
réchauffement climatique et qui se font
régulièrement attaquer sur les réseaux
sociaux x Twitter en tête dès que il
nous donne simplement ce que des
décennies de sciences leur permettent
d'affirmer bref ce sont d'autres
milliardaires les frères coachs qui
contribuent à se déballage chaque chaque
milliardaire en quelque sorte à sa cause
de ce point de vue là
Elon Musk n'est pas nécessairement en
général troisième élément peut-être
c'est qu'il y a mal gré tout un élément
de ce qu'on a appelé la fonction de
tribunicienne chez le polytologue
Georges Lavaux qu'est-ce que c'était
c'est une capacité malgré tout à attirer
tout un tas de personnes qui n'étaient
peut-être pas intéressés au premier plan
par la politique mais qui viennent aussi
par ce goût du clash donc en gros l'idée
que le j'allais dire le débat politique
certaines enceintes pour en prendre
d'autres mais sous des formes beaucoup
plus radicales vous êtes d'accord pour
dire Amel Guitton qu'il n'a pas lui-même
d'ambition politique
Elon Musk
j'ai pas l'impression qu'il en est
au sens de devenir un acteur politique
traditionnel sur la question de sur la
question de l'influence et c'est tout
autre chose sur la question
effectivement de son on pourrait dire
presque un projet politique au
idéologique ça c'est ça c'est encore
effectivement pas devenir président des
États-Unis on le sent pas tellement en
tout cas de dans cette dans cette dans
cette optique là mais
pour moi la question aussi vraiment
c'est pour ça que je j'évoquais la
possibilité qu'à un moment donné à la
machine se grippe c'est combien de temps
Twitter peut tenir par exemple s'il
décide de véritablement rendre le
service intégralement payant il va y
avoir une fuite d'utilisateurs
j'ai pas le 300 autour de 300 millions
300 millions que devient que devient la
plateforme s'il y a plus cette chambre
déco mondiale c'est pour le coup c'est
une vraie question et je pense que c'est
pour ça qu'on voit d'ailleurs d'autres
acteurs se positionner notamment le
fondateur de Twitter qui a lancé un
autre réseau social qui s'appelle blue
sky méta donc Facebook qui a lancé
Friends qui est là aussi quelque chose
qui est un peu sur le modèle de Twitter
comme si d'une certaine manière tous ces
acteurs se disaient il y a peut-être un
moment où il faudra un équivalent de
Twitter pour remplacer quelque chose qui
sera qui sera en train de s'effondrer ça
c'est une ça c'est une effectivement une
vraie inconnue et c'est là-dessus qu'il
est d'ailleurs assez difficile parfois
de lire véritablement ça sa stratégie
les relations entre Elon Musk et Donald
Trump puisque on dit est-ce qu'il roule
pour Donald Trump il se il se côtoient
il s'estime mutuellement qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire Olivier lascar
alors ils se sont côtoyés c'est-à-dire
dans le passé et du fait même de ses
activités et au premier chef dans
l'espace Space X te serait pas SpaceX
s'il n'avait pas bénéficié largement de
l'argent public de la NASA donc on l'a
vu au côté de tous les présidents ou
tous les personnalités importantes
politiques qui ont dirigé les Etats-Unis
depuis 20 ans on l'a vu au côté d'Obama
on l'a vu aux côtés d'Hillary Clinton et
quand Trump a été président de la
République on l'a vu au côté de Trump
parce que c'est à ce moment là que
SpaceX a pour la première fois envoyé
justement comme je le disais tout à
l'heure des gens vers l'ISF des
astronautes vers l'issent que il y avait
plus que les Soyouz qui faisaient ça
faisait des décennies je ne me trompe
pas que les Américains n'avaient pas
envoyé eux-mêmes des des astronautes oui
donc évidemment d'un point de vue du
symbole du point de vue de l'honneur
retrouvé il marquait des points
terribles et à ce moment-là Trump
président de la République dit aussi je
veux être le président dans un second
mandat qui finalement n'a pas eu lieu
puisque byden a été élu mais je vais
être le président du retour des
astronautes sur la lune donc les deux
agendas ce sont parfaitement
correspondus c'est pour ça qu'ils ont on
les a vu marcher main dans la main à un
moment donné et si aujourd'hui
musk est davantage du côté d'un d'un
Trump que que dans Biden c'est parce
qu'en gros il sent que Trump est
suffisamment fou pour aller à marche
forcée vers Mars ce que feront pas les
autres c'est plus un calcul de cette
ordre là qu'un calcul réellement
idéologique je veux dire Elon Musk n'est
pas un fasciste ou à mon sens c'est pas
du tout ça il va vers ce qui le servent
le mieux possible bien compris alors
justement sur cette conquête spatiale
quelques images dernier décollage de
SpaceX 26 août dernier enfin dernier
décollage avec des des humains justement
à bord la nasaï c'est spacie cat
astronautes vers la Station spatiale
internationale à bord de cette capsule
de Ragon et on va écouter Benji Reed qui
est le directeur principal du programme
de vol habité chez SpaceX
c'est un aspect merveilleux de ce que
nous espérons faire en tant
qu'entreprise SpaceX et tous nos
partenariats à savoir rendre la vie
multi planétaire cela signifie qu'il
faut prendre toute l'humanité et toute
la vie humaine et nous aider à atteindre
les étoiles et à aller dans des endroits
différents chaque fois que nous avons
l'occasion de faire voler des
astronautes vers la Station spatiale
internationale c'est un pas de plus vers
cet objectif
Amel Guiton c'est peut-être un côté
gagnant-gagnant parce qu'il y a une
concurrence internationale sur l'espace
qui est beaucoup plus forte aujourd'hui
qu'elle ne l'étaient il y a peut-être
qu'elle ne l'a jamais été d'ailleurs
avec beaucoup de nouveaux États qui qui
tentent de s'y mettre est-ce que Elon
Musk conforte la puissance spatiale
américaine bien sûr et il faut pas
oublier parce que quand même ça fait
aussi partie du personnage pour moi il y
a quand même un coup de génie je suis
pas une hyper spécialiste de l'espace
mais on m'a expliqué que il arrive
il est pas tellement pris au sérieux et
notamment parce qu'il ce projet de
réutiliser bien sûr et qu'à l'époque
tout le monde lui dit ça ne marchera
jamais faire revenir les lanceurs pour
pouvoir les réutiliser sauf qui sait
s'entourer il y arrive et à partir du
moment où il y arrive il a 10 ans
d'avance sur tout le monde donc
effectivement à ce moment-là il devient
un interlocuteur naturel de des pouvoirs
publics américains que ce soit enfin de
l'agence spatiale évidemment la NASA du
Pentagone
et il conforte effectivement cette
préminence américaine faut savoir que
j'avais regardé les chiffres mais sur
2022 il y a eu
180 lancements orbitaux dont 76
américains 61 de SpaceX donc aujourd'hui
effectivement c'est un c'est un acteur
ultra dominant il ne serait pas là où il
en est s'il n'avait pas eu effectivement
cette intuition qui pouvait arriver à
faire un truc que personne n'avait
jamais fait il n'y serait pas arrivé non
plus s'il n'y avait pas cette symbiose
avec avec les pouvoirs publics avec le
Pentagone notamment mais c'est aussi
quelque chose qu'on retrouve dans la
Silicon Valley cette symbiose entre le
public et le privé qui est aussi très
très particulière aux États-Unis mais
effectivement aujourd'hui c'est aussi
une symbiose qui fait que les États-Unis
ont une prééminence dans l'espace pour
le coup ils sont je pense que plus de la
moitié des des objets spatiaux au moins
sont les leurs
mais avec effectivement cette
particularité que c'est c'est aussi
quelqu'un de d'assez difficile à enfin
d'asser imprévisible et qui parfois est
manifestement encombrant et avec quand
même cette dimension on l'a bien compris
c'est la NASA et SpaceX c'est donc
l'argent public américain qui finance
les vols privés de SpaceX ça le rend
peut-être aussi un peu redevable
vis-à-vis de l'État américain vous voyez
ce que je veux dire dans dans son rôle
géopolitique et dans son influence
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de ça il
nous reste très peu de temps
malheureusement s'il faut le dire très
rapidement ce qui est frappant c'est
qu'effectivement alors que les Européens
aussi de se désengager en tout cas on se
dit disant que on est contre les
subventions publiques
qui a fait le choix complètement
contraire en fait et donc l'accusation
de protectionnisme des Européens que
nous font souvent les Américains et
absolument faux là-dessus oui ça le rend
en quelque sorte
tributaire des contrats qu'il a pu
signer mais imagine-t-on une
administration américaine dénoncer le
contrat ça aurait certains de
difficultés pour des contrats d'armement
qui sont en général plus longs que les
mandats des présidents américains 30
secondes il rêve vraiment de d'installer
une colonie humaine sur Mars je crois
complètement depuis toujours c'est son
obsession il pense que il pense que
c'est l'avenir de l'humanité il essaie
d'habiller ça de différents discours qui
sont souvent pas pertinents par exemple
il est complètement à côté de la plaque
quand il dit il faut aller sur mars
parce que on a tellement ratiboisé la
terre que elle pourra plus nous servir
c'est inaudible inaudible aujourd'hui à
d'autres moments il va flatter
l'aventure humaine etc bon mais oui son
obsession c'est mars et tout ce qu'il
fait doit être lu à l'aune de cette
obsession martienne bien la vie compris
c'est à retrouver dans votre livre
enquête sur Elon Musk l'homme qui défie
la Science publie aux éditions visio et
puis vous publiez également abis
l'ultime frontière chez le même éditeur
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat qui était passionnant la tête dans
les étoiles et malheureusement aussi au
cœur du conflit en Ukraine je vous dis à
lundi merci à toutes et à tous de votre
fidélité demain dans la matinale Oriane
mansigny reçoit un collègue un
journaliste François-Xavier ménage grand
reporter auteur de ce livre ça craque
une plongée dans la France qui galère
belle soirée à toutes et à tous